- How is it possible that modern
medicine recommends certain
treatments that are flat out wrong.
Well, that's what I asked Dr. Paul Offit,
the director of Vaccine Education Center
at Children's Hospital, Philadelphia
and member of the FDA
Vaccine Advisory Committee.
Yeah, he advises the FDA on
what vaccines to approve.
He's not just an advisor
though, but a vaccine creator,
having developed a rotavirus vaccine,
which is estimated to save
hundreds of lives per day
around the world.
Dr. Offit is also the author
of one of my favorite books,
"Overkill When Modern
Medicine Goes Too Far,"
which directly challenges
15 modern medical practices,
some of which you may
have experienced yourself.
Huge thanks to Audible
for sponsoring this video.
To start off Dr. Offit and I
discuss how important it is
to be skeptical, even with
modern or revolutionary medicine.
For example,
he attacks the established
practice of lowering every fever
and the overuse of antibiotics.
So I asked him what's one to do,
like for me as a young
family medicine physician,
like let's take the antibiotics
discussion on its own.
Your proponent for decreasing
lengths of antibiotic courses,
when appropriate, decreasing
the use of antibiotics,
when not appropriate,
it's easier said then done
then what is available in
clinical practice.
Patients come in with a certain
understanding that takes
a lot of time to debunk,
time that we oftentimes
don't have with the patients.
A lot of times they come in
with sort of expectations that
they should get the antibiotic.
And if they don't,
they will leave you a negative
review or negative score
on your after visit summaries.
And these are things that
active clinicians have
to think about in addition to the science.
And in addition to the worry
about what could potentially
go wrong with this patient.
What's your recommendation
to young doctors
around the world?
- Well, first of all, and I
would extend it to the hospital.
I mean, I don't see outpatients,
but I see inpatients in our
hospital and the physicians that
are taking care of these
patients want antibiotics.
They want them for a long period of time.
So the pressure doesn't
just come from parents
or from patients, it
also comes from doctors.
What my advice is,
is you know we're entering
a post antibiotic era.
I mean, we have children in our hospital,
especially some with say cystic
fibrosis, that are affected
with bacteria that are
resistant to all commercially
available antibiotics.
I mean, we're starting to
use bacteria face therapy,
meaning viruses that kill bacteria.
I don't know if you ever read
Sinclair Lewis's Arrowsmith
but I mean, that was
the subject of that book
written in the early 1920s
before we had antibiotics.
I mean,
we used to use bacteria
phages a hundred years ago.
It's a little frightening
that we're going back to that
at some level.
So that's, what's at stake.
And so for me, the attitude
is I certainly understand
where the parents are coming from
or in the case of the hospital
where the doctor's coming from.
But we have a judicious
use of antibiotics program
in our hospital and we push back.
And I think you have to do the same thing,
knowing that you will pay
a certain price for that,
but the eyes on the prize
and the prize is the child.
The prize is you wanna make
sure that you're not generating,
more and more resistant bacteria,
which will only be more and more difficult
to treat in that child.
So although the parent may want
it and may give you a better
review, do the right thing.
But as you know, doing the right thing,
isn't always doing the easy thing.
- The concept of medical
inertia you mentioned earlier,
I think is so well stated in the book.
I'd love for you to briefly touch on that.
- Yeah, we do things a certain way
and when you try and I know,
cause I've given talks relating
to things in this book.
And what you'll often hear
is push back from physicians
is look, I mean,
I've been doing it this way
for 20 years and it works well,
but see, you don't know that
if you don't do it that way,
that would also work, right?
So that's what you're up against.
You're up at this sort of anecdotal.
I've done this and it's
worked and it's like,
this is my experience,
but doing something wrong
a thousand times doesn't
constitute experience.
And also remember antibiotics
are not big money makers
for these pharmaceutical companies,
because there's something
you give just a few times say
at most, during the year,
you're not taking it every day.
They're never gonna compete
with lipid lowering agents
or neurological drugs or diabetes drugs.
So they're not a priority
for these companies.
And we're there.
We've taken our first steps
into the post antibiotic era.
And I working in a hospital.
I certainly see that
we've used bacteria phases
in our hospital, on children
with cystic fibrosis
who are infected with something that,
for which we have no antibiotics,
because we have pushed and
pushed and pushed that bacteria
into complete resistance.
The bacteria ultimately will win out.
They will win out unless
we're careful about
how we're handling all this.
- Yeah, antibiotic stewardship
is really important
and much in the same vein.
One of the obstacles
I run into quite often
is with fever reducing agents.
Frequently, even amongst
friends and family,
when they call me for advice,
when I tell them to not
use fever lowering agents,
when they have a very mild fever,
there's shock on their face,
because that is not something
that is generally talked
about and I don't understand
why it's not taught
in medical schools,
it's not discussed amongst my colleagues.
I've never had a lecture on it
despite attending thousands of lectures.
And yet there's so much
evidence that you stated in this
book about allowing a fever to
help inflammatory cytokines,
to help your immune
system function better,
to potentially decrease autoimmune
conditions in the future.
Why do we continue to
use fever lowering agents
and what can we do about it?
- Well, we continue to use them
because they makes us feel better.
It's a short lived gain,
but you're exactly right.
I mean, you put your finger on it.
Why don't we learn about this?
I mean, I really learned about it the most
when I read about it for the
purpose of writing the book.
There are probably 20 studies
showing that for people
who have let's say bacterial pneumonia
that are treated with antibiotics,
that they will have
either more severe disease
or longer lasting disease.
I mean, it's true over and
over again in the world
of vaccines, which is my world.
If you give antibiotics,
prior to getting a vaccine,
you lower the immune response
because why do we make fever?
It's not to keep pharmaceutical
companies in business.
We make fever because our
immune system works better
at a higher temperature.
And across the board B
cells make antibodies
sort of more efficiently
and at higher affinity
and higher titer.
T cells help B cells do it.
Cytotoxic T cells help kill
viral infected cells that,
but we pay a price for fever.
You pay a metabolic price for fever,
and it's uncomfortable having fever
which is why we only have
fever when we need it.
And so why blunt this critical aspect
of your immune response?
The one story I tell in the
book is it was so striking
was a 15 year old boy
who was playing soccer.
He's hitten in the hip with a soccer ball.
He develops a thrombus, a
clot in his, in the vein
at his hip.
Which becomes infected with
the bacteria staph aureus
which is resistant, right?
So methicillin-resistant staph aureus.
So we're treating with the
right antibiotic vancomycin
day after day though,
he continued to have bacteria
in his bloodstream because
they had this septic thrombophlebitis,
day after day after day,
continued to have high fever
and was treated round the clock
with anti fever medicines.
And after a while, I thought, you know,
why blunt this critical
aspect of the mirror by?
So I sat down with a boy who was brave.
I sat down with his parents
who were perfectly willing
to listen to what we had to say.
And most importantly
sat down with the nurses
because this is like one of
the pillars on which nursing
stands is thermo regulation.
So we all got in a room.
We had this discussion and we
stopped treating his fever.
And within two days his
blood culture cleared.
We finally cleared it.
Now that may have, that's
just the end of one.
It may have been coincidence,
but not as far as the parents
were concerned or the nurses.
They thought we were geniuses
because we just didn't
treat with antipyretic.
- Yeah, I think electronic
medical records definitely plays
a role here because it was so often that
automatically when you
were treating an infectious
disease patient,
the orders almost automatically went in
that if for fever above 101 give Tylenol,
it was like one of the orders
sets that auto populated
and I never understood
why that was the case.
I even intuitively coming out
as a resident felt like that
was wrong and I never
understood the logic.
Obviously, if we have
a patient who's weak,
who's not resting who has
cardiovascular risk, et cetera.
There might be indications for it.
But the whole majority of the population,
I never understood.
Even, I'm gonna throw
my father under the bus.
He's a physician who is
trained in USSR as a physician,
came to the United States,
went to medical school here again.
So that's two times medical school.
And yet when I was younger,
the second, my temperature went up,
you have to take aspirin,
you have to take Motrin something.
And I would argue with
him, why am I taking this?
Like, it didn't make sense to me.
And to this day,
he still believes treating
a fever is the right thing.
Because of, I think the concept
that you so well illuminate,
which is medical inertia.
It worked for him for
so long, keep doing it.
Why change what works?
Back to the interview in just a second.
But first I wanna thank Audible
for sponsoring this video.
I actually found Dr. Offit book
"Overkill When Modern
Medicine Goes Too Far"
on Audible and listening
to it was so interesting.
I had to have him on the
channel to discuss it more.
I listen to Audible every time
I'm on the go, in the gym,
going to the hospital, even walking bare.
I love it because it
allows me to multitask.
So I listen to what I've got in my ear
or on my car speakers.
And I'm still able to do other stuff.
All you have to do to get started is go
to audible.com/drmike or text Dr. Mike
to the number 500-500.
Remember though doctor is
spelled out and by signing up,
you're gonna get a free 30 day
trial, as an Audible member
you get access to one credit a
month that can be used on any
title from their premium selection,
such as the latest best sellers.
You also get access to
the Audible plus catalog,
which has guided meditations
podcast and so much more.
The link is down below.
Let's get back to our
interview with Dr. Offit.
Next, we moved on to how
marketers and big tech CEOs
have sold us this false notion
of maximally optimizing health,
moving many from a fact
based health system
to a faith based system.
Because we desperately
wanna believe in magic,
but I'm a skeptic of biohacking.
So I ask in the space where I function,
which is primarily in social media.
Anything that has new tech involved,
Silicon Valley money in
it, people get excited,
Elon Musk tweets about it,
and it becomes a huge story to
the general public that they
think they found a shortcut
to treating some illness,
improving abilities, optimizing health.
And it could not be
further from the truth.
Because in medicine,
unless you're a clinician,
you may not realize that
changing one thing will change
three other things down the
line that you completely didn't
expect or completely negates
whatever it is that you tried
to do in the first place.
Have you seen biohacking in
the hospital with your patients
in media?
Have you spoke about that at all?
- Not really, I guess to me,
probably the best example would
be something like Theranos.
You know were here you have
just this one finger prick
of blood, just that would
fill up a very tiny sort
of micro cuvette,
that where you can do 200 or 300 tests,
which already was like
other worldly, right?
I mean, because there's no
way you're gonna be able
to do 200 tests unless
you dilute those samples.
And every time you dilute
something you lose information
and things become less reliable.
It never made sense to me
and what was interesting was
when it first appeared, right?
Because it was, that's exactly right.
It was like, Silicon Valley
big tech, she got, you know,
Elizabeth Holmes got billions
and billions of dollars
of valuation and got
major players to stand up
and be like George
Schultz, at the very least
and Madison and stuff.
And it was just built on
sand and it never made sense.
And I remember reading
about science or nature
which are excellent scientific journals
that also bought into it.
This was like, even the
highest of which should be
skepticism was just we wanted to believe.
So we'd gone from sort
of science to religion,
we moved from a fact based
system to a belief system,
which is never a good idea.
- Do you think it's excitement
over the potential progress
that we could be making
that's leading us to look
the other way?
- Yes, you wanna believe,
you wanna believe we're we can be magical.
We believe, we do believe
in magic as it turns out.
- That's true.
Some of the examples that I
have written down that I wanted
to discuss is anything
related to metabolism tracking
has been created as if or
labeled as if it's the next great
thing, the next answer for everything.
And what the reality for me
as a practicing physician
is more information is not always better.
In fact, it's confusing
and it makes it difficult
to treat a patient.
For example, the Apple
Watch does a fantastic job
at tracing your heart rate and telling you
when you have a moment
of atrial fibrillation.
But when a patient brings that
in who's otherwise healthy,
who's 20 years old and
had two seconds of A-fib.
I have no idea what to do with it,
because the evidence has not
told me what to do with it.
Have you ever had a
conversation with a patient
with some kind of tech issue like this?
- No, no, I mean, I'm not an IT guy,
so it's not (indistinct) these guys,
so no, that hasn't come
up, but you're right.
I mean, I think we, like,
we want that simple thing,
that single thing, this sort
of this reductionist thinking,
that one magical thing
that we can point to.
So no, that hasn't happened.
I'm an older physician.
So this is gonna be much
more of a phenomenon
for you than me (indistinct).
- That makes sense.
For me, I see it as almost
an extension of your book.
For example, screening programs,
I follow the guidance of the United States
Preventive Service Task Force.
When I look at what screening programs
I should be involved in.
To me, a screening test should be able
to spot an illness early
in an asymptomatic,
otherwise healthy person,
and allow me to intervene meaningfully.
And there's a lot of things
where we were doing early on
your example, being prime,
prostate cancer screening,
we would check everyone's PSAs,
find all these false positives
or positives that were
related to BPH and not
actually prostate cancer
that led to further extra testing.
That was a necessary side
effects from this testing
downstream negative effects.
But still to this day,
I have urologists that are
writing blogs that are actually
speaking down to the fact
that family physicians are not
ordering PSAs as regularly as we used to.
Again, it seems like
it's with good intention,
but then it creates all
these downstream problems
that we weren't ready to face.
Your experience in medicine is vast.
Tell us how to stop doing and
remaking the same mistakes
over and over again.
- So when you say my
experience in medicine is vast,
but you're really trying
to say in a nice way,
is that I'm old, got it, I'm with you.
- No wisdom, wisdom, wisdom.
- No, I mean, that's a perfect example.
And first of all, the PSA wasn't
designed for that purpose,
it wasn't designed as a
cancer screening test.
And so what was interesting to me,
the analogy that I loved
actually in the writing this book
was sort of this barnyard
analogy of this sort
of the turtles, the rabbits, or the birds.
A screening test is a value
if you screen somebody who
had you not screened them
and picked something up,
they would've died otherwise.
So that's it.
So therefore that screening
test prolongs your life.
That's a good screening test.
So I think colonoscopy
reasonably prolongs your life
and pap smears reasonably
prolong your life.
But prostate cancer, if you look at people
who go through this sort
of standard, get PSAs,
a PSA is high, get a biopsy.
If biopsy shows, you know,
worse, something gets worrisome,
go through radiation
therapy or surgical therapy.
There should be clear evidence
that people that go through
that live longer than
people who don't go through
any of that, and there isn't.
Which means that the people
who are going through that
are doing a lot of suffering in terms
of either radiation
therapy or surgery or both.
And that's what was really striking to me.
So it's like the, what
you want is you want,
you really trying to,
what you really care
about is you care about
the sort of the rabbit.
So you open up the barn
door, the turtle is not gonna
get out while you open that
barn door cause he's so slow.
So that's like the cancer that
you die with and not from.
And a large percentage of people
in their eighties die with
prostate cancer, but not from it.
Meaning when you do
look at their prostate,
they have obvious cancer lesions.
And then there's the bird
that it doesn't matter
whether you try and
close the door quickly,
you're gonna, the bird flies out anyway,
that's the cancer you're gonna die from
no matter what you do.
So it's the rabbits,
you're trying to like,
here's the rabbit coming.
You close the during in
time and you save your life.
But mostly prostate cancer is
a lot of turtles and birds.
I mean, it's not like people
don't die of prostate cancer.
They do.
The question is where's the
odds that by the time you've
made that diagnosis,
you're already past a point
where you're gonna save their life.
I mean, I watched my father
go through this and go through
radiation and surgery,
ultimately for his cancer.
And he suffered a lot and
that last he was incontinent,
it was difficult for him.
And I just don't think they did anything
to prolong his life.
They just, but I said,
once you're diagnosed
with cancer, you know,
people now have this notion,
please get this out of me.
You know, you can't just say, look,
you're probably gonna
die with it, not from it.
So don't worry about it because
people are worried about it.
So it's hard.
- Yeah, what's your take
on specialists pushing back
on some of these arguments
and saying, well,
we've updated the way that
we treat these patients.
We've instituted watchful
waiting, rechecking numbers,
not necessarily jumping to biopsies,
perhaps other types of
scanning and imaging.
Do you think that warrants
further testing before continuing
the recommendation of screening everybody?
- Well, yeah, I think that's happening
at least that's my sense,
but I like you go with this
sort of preventive task force
recommendations cause I think
they're the most informed.
But they've moved away from
this sort of, you know,
the sort of constant, PSA
testing and then biopsying
they've slowly moved away from that.
Which I really like.
I think that's bold,
but get people to understand
that is the hard part.
I mean, that's,
I mean, I'm a pediatric
infection disease specialist,
so I don't have to worry about
trying to convince people not
to get PSAs or biopsies, but I did.
I mean, I got, I had very high PSAs
and they wanna do biopsies
and the biopsies were questionable.
It's like, I finally just said, forget it,
just let me die of prostate cancer
if I'm gonna die of prostate cancer.
And Levi, and this was years ago.
So prostate cancer hasn't gotten me
and I suspect it never will.
I maybe I'll die with
prostate cancer, but I just,
I realized that more and
more I read and it was in the
writing this book that
that was all happening.
I just thought, this is ridiculous.
Why are we doing this?
And I remember going to the
urologist who was recommending
all this and saying,
I just can't see evidence
for why we're doing this,
how it helps me.
And he was unconvincing and he,
but he took its credit, he
let me sort of do it my way.
- What's interesting is I keep
running into the same issue
in speaking with you,
because I feel like you're
almost like a primary care doctor
in the sense of the issues
you bring up in your writing.
These are all of the same issues
I run into in my practice,
whether it's antipyretics,
the antibiotics,
the screening programs,
all of these problems start
in the primary care visit
at least with me.
And one of those issues is
supplementation and the promising
of miracle cures, we
will fix what ails you,
if you don't need a healthy diet,
your insurance pill is the multivitamin.
That is probably as a young doctor,
who's on the internet making
a lot of content that I speak
down upon in terms of saying
that you don't need these things.
I get the biggest pushback on.
Vitamin D is something you've
written about in your book.
Something I frequently,
frequently push back on specialists on.
I have dermatologists that put my patients
with a target goal of 70
for their vitamin D levels.
And I'm like, where is the
evidence for what you're doing?
Or even the endocrinology societies,
not pushing back hard on
these other specialties.
What do we do about sort of
fighting back against the
misinformation that supplements
are the cure or they are
what's missing in order
to keep us healthy?
What do we do for the general public here?
- It's the zeitgeist.
I mean, it is just the
way things are right now.
So you're pushing up
against this tremendous wave
of our culture that wants this magic pill.
And we've convinced
people that, and it's easy
to convince them because I
think if you poll people,
most people will not think
that they eat particularly
healthy diets.
I had a pizza last night for dinner
and a sub for lunch today.
And so people say like
their bodies are temples,
that's how they worship them.
Well, mine's more like,
this sort of garbage dump
where raccoons kind of
like hang out in forage,
but that's more me, but.
- I love the honesty, I love the honesty.
Now we need more of that.
- So it's easy then for
people to say, look,
if you don't happen to eat
a particularly healthy diet,
here's this pill that will make it so that
you'll get everything that you need.
But the fact of the matter
is you get it pretty much
everything you need in foods, independent,
whether or not you eat what
is considered a healthy diet
or not for the most part.
And you're right.
The vitamin D story was
really interesting to me
because you're right.
I mean, it's not,
I mean, I'm in the world of
pediatric infectious diseases.
This doesn't come up a
lot, but it was really ,
I went into this, the book,
this book was one of the books
was "Do You Believe in Magic?
The Sense of Nonsense
of Alternative Medicine"
in addition to overkill,
that was just sort of skeptical
look at at these therapies.
And I kept wanting to find
something that showed that
say supplements work,
because otherwise just come
off as a complete naysayer.
And I had a lot of trouble
finding that evidence for that.
I mean, 'cause vitamin D
has been argued for a cure
or preventive for everything,
cancer, strokes, heart attacks.
I mean, this is the even medicine.
- I don't know where they.
- That's right, even falls,
that's right, that's right.
- So there were some
recommendations early on
that were shocking to me
and skin health, everything,
but no one wanted to
believe that taking vitamins
can actually lead to more harm.
And I think your book
illuminates both of those points.
Can you tell us we're
taking supplements outside
of taking supplements that have arsenic
or some other toxic elements to them,
but vitamins on their own can be harmful.
Tell us about that.
- Well, it's obviously vitamins
are critical, vital life.
I mean, you need vitamins are substances
which your body needs, but
cannot make on its own.
You need vitamins that's not the issue.
The issue is how best to get them.
And the answer is the best
way to get them is from food.
I give credit to the
nutritional supplement companies
for being able to sell
what they sell as natural
because it's not natural.
That's not how your body is
meant to take in vitamins
in a compressed pill
that has a large quantity
of vitamin that is not associated
with the other phytochemicals
that are typically found
in vegetables and fruits.
And when you do it that way,
you're not preventing it,
presenting it in natural, right.
You're presenting it in an unnatural way,
which can then have consequences.
And that's what we found
out now that the vitamin C
can have consequences when
taking large quantities.
So can vitamin D, et
cetera, vitamin E, I mean.
So it surprises me they
don't have black box warnings
on them and they would have
black box warnings on them
for these sort of multivitamins
or the sort of high level of
vitamins that people take.
If the FDA was able to regulate them.
But that Dietary Supplement
Health and Education Act
pushed back against the FDA on this.
And so the FDA doesn't
really regulate them
the way they should, so people don't know.
And that's what was also
interesting to me is just,
here, you talk about going
up against the zeitgeist
of the current culture of
the desire to take a pill,
but go up against these
nutritional supplement companies.
I mean, they have an
enormous amount of money
and influence and I just
feel so sorry for the patient
who's caught up in all this.
- Because I think people push
towards the supplement space
for two reasons.
One, they think it's natural,
which is incorrect as you put right now.
And the second is that
they believe against
pharma companies.
They have a negative biased
view of pharma companies,
which is important.
I think we need to take
a skeptical look about
how pharma companies do their
testing, their approvals,
their pricing especially.
But the reality of pharma
companies getting rich off
of selling a certain medications.
And the point you brought up,
which I think is an understated
point that pharma companies
love creating drugs
that patients would take
for years upon years and daily,
as opposed to finding cures,
as opposed to finding the
new antibiotic is probably
the worst form of how pharma functions.
But these nutritional supplement
companies that pawn off
their supplements as natural are also
billion dollar entities
just like the pharma companies,
except with no regulation
like they're both billionaire companies.
One is forced to prove
that their medications work
or what their side effects can be.
And one has free reign
to do whatever they want.
And yet the public doesn't scrutinize
the nutritional companies at all.
- It's amazing.
I mean, I'm on the FDA Vaccine
Advisor Committee, right?
So we sit down and we did
say in December 10th or 17th,
take over Pfizer's vaccine
and then Moderna's vaccine,
those were 40,000 person
studies, 30,000 person studies.
You know, where you get a
200 pages of material to read
before you go through the meeting,
where you look at every piece
of data in terms of safety
and efficacy.
And then, and only then do you
make sort of a recommendation
to move forward on those vaccines
and then nutritional supplement
companies just make it up.
I mean, what's on the label
doesn't necessarily have
to be what's in the bottle
and people feel much more
comfortable with that
than they do with this
highly regulated, highly
supervised and scrutinized process.
It is remarkable.
I give credit to these
companies for having sold us
a bill of goods.
And I also give credit to mother nature.
I don't know who her
public relations team is,
but I wanna hire that group
because she has been trying
to kill us ever since
we crawled out of the ocean on the land.
I mean, when people say we'll
go, so as far as to say,
they wanna have like a
natural COVID infection,
as you know, because that's
better than getting a vaccine.
- Yeah, look, in some
ways like a natural fever
is better than blocking a fever.
So I kind of see where that started,
but then there's like this
element of concept creep,
which Jonathan Height talks about so well
where natural can be better.
It doesn't mean that it's always better.
And you know certain toxins are natural,
doesn't mean that we
should be taking them in.
Dr. Offit sits on the FDA
Vaccine Advisory Committee,
which means he advises the FDA
on which vaccines to approve
or not approve.
Which is why I found it so
interesting to learn how critical
he is of both the Biden
and Trump administrations,
politicization of health guidance.
Do you think that a part of
this is the loss of trust
in medical institutions?
- Oh, certainly.
Absolutely, and I think
that wasn't always true.
I mean, I was a child of the fifties
and I'll give you a perfect example.
When Jonas Salk made his polio vaccine.
He took the virus, grew it up in cells
in the laboratory, he purified it,
he killed it with the
chemical formaldehyde.
So it was a whole killed viral vaccine.
And then five companies
stepped forward to make it.
One of them made it badly,
Cutter Laboratories of
Berkeley, California
failed to fully inactivate the polio virus
that was in their vaccine.
It's a consequence,
120,000 children primarily
in the West and Southwest
were inoculated with live fully virulent,
fully dangerous polio virus.
40,000 developed short-lived polio,
meaning temporary paralysis.
164 were permanently paralyzed
for the rest of their life.
And 10 were killed.
I think it was the single
worst biological disaster
in this country's history.
And in no sense, shook
faith in the polio vaccine.
People generally believed
the companies were trying
to do their best.
If you looked at the exit
interviews from all the original,
those early lawsuits against
Cutter, you would see that
the people who were sitting on those rooms
saw what this was,
which was a scale up incident
that we just hadn't figured
out how to mass produce that vaccine yet.
And wanted to find Cutter
not guilty, not responsible
amazingly enough but and because
they trusted the companies,
they trusted the government,
they trusted the medical
community and something changed.
I think in the sixties and
seventies, something changed.
I mean, it became much more
cynical, much more litigious,
sort of what I call kind of
the post Watergate phenomenon,
where we saw that there were
sort of evil forces lurking
behind the curtains,
whether it's Pentagon papers
or the Nixon tapes when
there was a loss of trust.
- Yeah, do you think the CDC or the FDA
can be functioning in a more
effective way when it comes
to communication with the general public,
whether it's about vaccines
or vitamin supplements,
because it feels like
there's somehow a gap.
The FDA makes statements,
you have medical experts go
on good morning, America,
et cetera, but yet the
efficacy isn't there.
It's almost like how we talk about
some of the things you
mentioned in your book.
We do them just to do them
with no evidence behind them.
If the FDA issues a press
release and no one reads it
and it changes, no one's mind,
shouldn't we be looking at
other ways of communicating with
the general public.
- Yes, I think there has
been during COVID especially
there has been a real loss
of trust in the public
health agents, agencies and
public health officials.
I think, and at some level deservedly so.
I think that if you look at
what happened in the previous
administration and president
Trump's administration,
what you saw was you saw
that the administration could
actually arm twist the FDA,
arm twist them into approving
through emergency use
authorization hydroxychloroquine.
An anti-malarial drug that
had never been shown to work,
to either treat or prevent
COVID, and they approved that.
I mean, they, three months later,
they took away the approval
when it was shown not to work
and shown to have heart
arrhythmias, which could be fatal.
But that really shook people's confidence.
I mean, so much so that before
the vaccine was released
in December, people were so worried about
what the Trump administration would do
was that states didn't trust the FDA
or the FDA Vaccine Advisory Committee
and formed their own advisory committees.
That's how bad it was.
Also, I do think now, for example,
if fantasies could come true,
I would like to do what,
communicate COVID the way we communicated
the swine flu pandemic in 2009.
I mean, so if here was a pandemic
that came into this country
and killed about 12,000 people.
It was a worldwide
pandemic with this novel
strain of influenza virus.
About 2% of the worldwide
deaths occurred in this country.
About a little more than 12,000
people died of that virus
in this country.
Every day, every other day,
there was Richard Besser,
head of the CDC telling
you where things stood
and why should it have been him
because all the data you cared about,
all the epidemiological
data came from the CDC
didn't come from NIH, didn't
come from the administration,
came from the CDC, also where
is the CDC, it's in Atlanta.
So he was always giving his
conferences from Atlanta.
Now, what you see is you see
these proclamations coming out
of Washington and
therefore they are subject
to political influence.
I mean, if fantasies could
come true I would like to see
Dr. Rochelle Walensky do all the talking
out of her passion in Atlanta,
because that's where we,
that's really all that
the stuff's coming and
it's like radio silence.
I mean, you don't hear anything.
And what Besser understood
was that the media
were the voices of the people.
Those were the questions of the people
that the people had to answer
and he answered them
patiently every other day.
It was great and we have
gotten away from that.
And it's hard, I mean, I'm
only as a voting member
of the FDA Vaccine Advisory Committee.
It's hard to watch some of these things.
I mean, it's not just
the Trump administration.
When president Biden stood
up on August 18th and said,
as of September 20th,
we are going to have a
booster dose of COVID vaccine
for everybody over 60.
Where did that come from?
I actually called a senior
official in the White House
and said, where is this coming from?
Where are the data that
drives that recommendation?
And in fact,
we kept pushing back on that
recommendation to Omicron hit,
and then sort of the floodgate's
open for booster dosing.
And I'm still a little lost
about for whom this is a two
dose vaccine, for whom
it's a three dose vaccine,
for whom it's a four dose vaccine
and where boosters fit into any of this.
Honestly, if you ask 10 Americans,
what does it mean to be fully vaccinated?
You'd probably get 10 different
answers because it's that
confusing and I blame us
for that, I do, I think.
- And that's not a general American issue,
that's a doctor issue.
Patients asking me the same.
And depending on their age,
I make like a clarification statement.
But the reality is we
don't know, you know,
nature had a good publication
showing a lot of efficacy
for second booster for
those over the age of 60.
But it matters that nuance matters.
And I feel like nuance is lost,
especially on social media.
I don't know how active you are
on Twitter and other sources
in terms of reading
what others are saying.
But the second you have disagreement,
even amongst educational sources,
whether it's someone from
Hopkins talking to someone from
Stanford, if there is even a
small amount of disagreement,
there's a lot of labeling that occurs
where if you don't fully
stand with the FDA or CDC,
you're critique for even one bit.
It somehow means you're
taking an anti-vax stance
or furthering the anti-vax agenda.
Is that type of labeling necessary?
Is it against what we're
trying to achieve in your eyes?
- Well, of course, I mean,
I think SNL, Saturday Night
Live had sort of a comedy skit
on that, where you had
a group of sort of maybe
three couples sitting
around a table in New York.
And one of them started saying, you know,
questioning whether or not
you really needed to mask
in a particular situation.
And then that person was vaporized.
It was like, right you
can't question it all.
Right now things are so confusing.
I'm not sure well, what
exactly the story is.
We, the committee, FDA Vaccine
Advisor Committee are gonna
be meeting the end of
June to pick strengths
for what I think they
want to have as a yearly,
or at least every sort of late fall,
early winter booster dose.
And I don't understand the
thinking there, I don't.
I'm on the committee and
I'm supposed to be picking
strengths and the way I see this,
why do we get a yearly flu vaccine?
We get a yearly flu vaccine
because even if you've been
vaccinated or infected the year before,
you're still at risk for serious disease.
For the most part protection
against serious disease holds
up with this vaccine.
I do think that for some this
is truly a three dose vaccine.
I do, that third dose,
when given four to six months
later increases your frequency
of memory B and T socially,
that you are better protected
against serious disease,
and that's the immune component
associated with protection
against serious disease,
people over 65, people
who have comorbidities.
I still can't quite fathom the
clear evidence that a healthy
less than 50 year old really
benefits from a third dose
in terms of protection
against serious illness,
which is the goal, unless
that's not the goal,
unless the goal is
preventing mild illness.
In which case we're gonna
have to keep boosting
because neutralized, again,
buys, always fade at some level
three or six months after a vaccination.
So is that the goal in which
case we're always gonna be
boosting, which is great
news for pharma companies.
I'm just not sure it's
necessarily good news for us.
- Is there any truth to the
fact that if we decrease
the likelihood of
developing mild infections,
that we decrease new
strains from coming about?
- Well, first of all, good luck with that.
I mean, this is a short
incubation period disease.
The viremia virus spread in
the bloodstream is not an
important part of the disease process
for these kinds of short
incubation period diseases.
The goal is to, the only reasonable goal,
the only achievable goal is
to prevent really moderate
to severe. So I was fortunate
enough to be part of a team
at Children's Hospital in Philadelphia.
They created the strains that
became the rotavirus vaccine
rota attack, that was a 26 year effort.
I am the co inventor of
the rotavirus vaccine.
That is a mucosal
infection like SARS-CoV-2,
meaning short incubation period
infects of mucosal surface.
When you have short incubation periods,
you are not going to be able
to protect for any length
of time against mild
asymptomatic infection.
I mean, we have eliminated
essentially with our vaccine
hospitalizations in babies from
rotavirus, we've done that,
but the virus still
circulates in the community.
That's gonna be true here too.
We're not gonna prevent mild disease.
And so I think what
people worry about now,
well was if it's true,
if I get mild disease,
can I still get long COVID?
And I don't wanna get a mild disease
and even people on the CDC
Advisory Committee just last week
said, we have to have a better
vaccine against mild disease.
Well, if you want a better
vaccine against mild disease,
figure out a way to lengthen
the incubation period,
because otherwise you're
gonna have trouble doing that.
It's just, it's hard to watch.
I think coming off this zero
tolerance strategy for COVID,
we're gonna have to realize
mild disease is gonna be part
of this for the rest of our lives.
I mean, this virus is
gonna circulate for decades
and it's gonna continue
to cause mild illness.
And even if the entire
world were vaccinated,
that would still be true.
And I don't think people
quite understand that.
- State medical boards exist
to keep doctors ethically
and legally in check.
Yet too often, doctors get
away with placing profits
over patients.
Considering Dr. Offit,
is well versed in the art
of the snake oil salesman I asked him,
do you think medical boards
should be taking a more
proactive stance here in sort
of disciplinary action wise?
- Yes, I do.
And they don't.
I mean, I'm right now,
I'm an Avalon New Jersey three
blocks from now, from here,
there is an IV vitamin treatment center.
It's actually right next to a bar.
And one of the ways that they
promote themselves is to say
kind of detox yourself
after drinking too much.
Yeah, I mean, I think the,
I think as generally licensing agencies,
ethics boards are terrible.
We are terrible as physicians
about pleasing ourselves,
terrible and so who pleases us.
In theory, lawyers please us, but there,
they don't really sue
so much for bad care,
as much as they sue for bad outcomes,
which are always gonna be true.
So that's not an effective
way to please us.
No, I think you're exactly right or people
who recommend against
vaccines or, you know, but it,
and it's all marketing, right?
I mean, I think that some
physicians realize there is,
this is, they can with
a boutique practice,
you can look like you care.
You're buying into the zeitgeist here
these magic pills that will
make you healthier and better
and have better sex and thicker hair,
whatever it is that they're promoting.
And it's hard to watch and we are terrible
at really regulating ourselves here.
And that's why everybody
gets away with it.
- Yeah, like I thought that by
starting my YouTube channel,
reaching millions of people,
I mean, monthly, we get 70,
80 million viewers on our YouTube channel.
And I thought if I could talk
about why there's no evidence
for some of these things or
why I don't believe they work
and explain the science behind
it, people would listen.
And while some people do the
frequent pushback I get is
you're a young doctor.
You didn't go to an Ivy League School.
You don't understand the
science that this person
is talking about.
But when I've even been
approached by these companies
to promote their product,
I would love to promote
a product that cures,
like some of the illnesses
that they talk about,
because I deal with them in
my practice and I see how much
they hurt my patients.
I would love to have a pill to say,
oh, you have irritable
bowel syndrome that destroys
your life, here is a
probiotic to solve it.
It just doesn't exist.
And when the companies come to me,
they flood me with
10,000 pages of research.
And when I really spend the
hours looking at the research,
they don't even prove that
their probiotic pill works.
They prove that their
probiotic pill survives
in the acidic environment in the stomach.
And somehow that means it works.
But the reality is they make
you look at the cool stuff
on one hand, but don't
really substantiate it
with anything else.
And I feel almost powerless
to attack it because you can't
attack something like you said,
in the beginning of this interview
that you can't say with
definite proof does not work.
I can't say with a hundred percent proof,
those probiotics don't work.
I could say, there's no
evidence that they work.
How do we attack this
industry more effectively?
- I think we at the very
least, we have to show that
there are downsides.
That anything that has a positive effect
can have a negative effect
and that you can see now
with the, cause I think
people don't know that.
People don't know that for example,
if you take these high
quantities of vitamin C that you
increase your risk of hit
kidney stones, for example.
And that can be serious as
just one of many examples.
And I think people don't, this con,
this industry has gotten
away with this notion,
this false notion that it's all positive
and nothing bad can happen.
That's never true in medicine.
If there's, if something
doesn't have a negative effect,
it probably never had a positive effect.
And I just think we need
to pull the curtain back
because I do think that works
at some level when people see
some of the fairies nature of
the way that this all works.
But I would like to say one
thing in case we're gonna end
soon, is I am really happy
there are people like you
out there.
I mean, young people who
are skeptical as physicians
that really are looking
behind the curtain here.
It is heartening to me to
know that you're out there.
Thank you for being out there.
- Well, honestly, inspired
by you and your skepticism,
because I always feel in medicine,
you need to have a very
strong balance between being
a healthy skeptic and not
disbelieving any new innovation
in technology,
because it's very easy to fall
into that trap where anything
new is bad and we don't
want to go that route.
And at the same time to say
anything revolutionary must
remove everything that we've done.
That's time tested and proved and proven.
So to me,
I actually just did an interview
for Medscape the other day
about the differences
between older physicians
and younger physicians.
And the answer wasn't one or the other.
I don't prefer one or the other.
In fact, it's the collaborative
approach of the two
let's learn what worked over the years.
Let's take the younger approach,
how we can make technology work with us
instead of against us,
but not sell out to these
hedge fund companies
that wanna run medicine in a
way that makes the checkbook
get a little thinner,
get the wallet thinner,
as opposed to our waste thinner.
To me, that's the most
disheartening thing.
I think that medicine is
becoming to be a hedge fund
in the business world.
And that happens even in the
telemedicine front, you'll see,
like we had to go virtual for
the first few months of COVID
because our office shut down.
And I saw how ineffective
this was in so many
of my patient's cases.
Good luck treating or figuring
out abdominal pain through
a virtual exam, virtually
worthless, I would say.
But there were some utility to it.
And now what I see online is
all these companies popping up,
do a virtual visit,
five minutes with our
doctor will give you Viagra,
will give you antibiotics,
will give you Propecia.
Will make your hair grow thicker
with no checking to see is
this patient having erectile dysfunction
because of severe diabetes.
Is this patient having a
fungal infection under scalp
and that's why they're losing hair.
And all of these things are
sort of corrupting medicine.
And I wanna be the one
pressing the brakes and saying,
let's be good marketers and
see what marketers do well,
but push the evidence based approach
with the marketing, spin on it.
And that's sort of an optimistic,
maybe unrealistic goal
that I've had with my YouTube channel.
I don't know what your
take on that would be.
- Now, I think that's absolutely
great, I congratulate.
I think it's a, skepticism
is healthy, a cynicism isn't
and so be open-minded to
the day to the fact that
there may be data that
contradicts something you believe
is true, have believed it was true.
But don't be so cynical that
you don't believe clear,
compelling, reproducible data.
- Frequently patients
and friends will claim
that they've done their research,
which usually means they
did a quick Google search
or read a Facebook thread.
With everyone these days,
considering themselves,
some sort of expert.
I had to ask him in
your book, "Bad Advice"
you talked about how you
shouldn't take for the average
person, shouldn't take advice
from politicians, celebrities,
activists, who should
they take advice from?
- Well, you know it's the experts.
I mean, it's, we don't like that term,
this now in the 21st century, you know,
trust me I'm an expert,
that's not exactly something it sells.
But that is true when people say to me
I've done my research on
the chickenpox vaccine
and I've decided not to get it.
Well, what do they really
mean by do their research?
What they really mean is
they've read people's opinions
about the vaccine on the internet.
I mean, if they really
wanna do their research
on the chickenpox vaccine,
well, they should do,
they should read the roughly
300 papers that have been
published on the vaccine,
which would require some
expertise in virology, immunology,
epidemiology, et cetera.
Most people don't have that expertise.
Frankly, most doctors
don't have that expertise.
So what do they do?
They rely on expert advisory bodies, like,
FDA Advisory Committees
and CDC Advisory Committees
that at least collectively
have read those papers,
collectively have an expertise
to evaluate those papers.
And then collectively make
a decision about whether
the vaccine is of value.
But you know that people
just don't do that.
And you can't,
it's dismissive these days to
say anything like, you know,
you really should rely on
informed opinions based on data
doesn't work because
people believe they can be
just informed by Googling the
word VA, chickenpox vaccine
as anybody else which isn't true.
And I just, you know, so try
and explain that to people.
It's hard.
I mean, it is hard.
- I think I share some
empathy for the average member
of the public, because we
say to look to the CDC,
the FDA for guidance, and you
sit on the ACIP committee.
And yet you're saying that
the FDA's pushing some things
along that you just
frankly don't agree with
and it's confusing to
how it's gotten there.
- Well, I sit on the
FDA committee actually.
I used to be on the CDC.
So I've been on both
committees, you're right.
And I think what happens
is it's not the committees
that are the problem.
It's when the administration
bypasses the committee.
When president Biden stood
up in August of last year
and said, we're gonna offer
booster doses for everybody.
He bypassed the FDA and
bypassed the CDC, that's bad.
That's a bad thing to do.
- So we as medical
experts should keep church
and state separate in the
sense of church being science
and state being government,
because it's very clear
how that undo influence
cannot only directly
harm those institutions,
but also hurt the public trust.
- Yes, I agree.
- Natural remedies aren't all bad.
In fact, here, I've compiled
a list of 10 natural remedies
that actually work.
Click here to check that
out and as always stay happy
and healthy, I'll see you in
the natural remedies video.
(upbeat music)